foreign
foreign
thank you
assalamualaikum
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the Dunya the three Muslims how you
guys doing today
bro why did you smile like that as soon
as we we started the stream
I just can't help but smile man to be
honest I'm the love bro
I'm excited man this is gonna be a real
one
315 viewers on the live
on her bro how many likes should that be
bro come on now
come on now
you already know that's at least five
at least 500. yes sir 315 viewers but it
should be 500 likes what are you guys
doing smash that like button this is not
click bait to clear the air a lot of
people wonder that there's generally
some things that meet on me and Angel
were talking about that are things that
I believe and as a collective we we see
the value in addressing these things
someone writes Charizard always looking
asleep deprived
oh
that's
that's like slander man you're basically
saying I look
nice no what
bro do I do I really look sleep deprived
all the time
it's only my eyes bro my eyes are just
always low set
hmm
Miller bless you bro I see the moon on
your face
how are things going with your your
actual lives We're not gonna make small
talk too long as soon as we have like
let's say 500 viewers 600 viewers we're
just gonna go right in
uh so how's everything going with you
guys
I'm a little depressed bro I'm not gonna
lie
why are you stressed bro just look
outside man like three four feet of snow
um if you live in an area where the
management is not really on top of you
know assaulting everything and Paving
everything like me then it's tough bro
like if you go outside and you know if I
don't have long socks there's like that
little area of my ankle showing you know
I'm trying to work on that because I'm
trying to have high up but that little
area snow gets in there bro and then it
just goes into my shoe and that's the
most frustrating thing I've ever brought
Arnold has no idea what that is bro
because he's uh Floridian yeah I've
never heard of Saltine
assaulting the salt melts the snow
yeah no I know that but I've never never
heard of it okay how are things uh where
you are around me keep the location
Anonymous
um
it's horrible
I tried very hard not to say like it's a
frozen hell because stuff with all of
them but it's it's really bad like
uh bro like I don't know how many feet
of snow we got it was like maybe five
feet something crazy literally bro I
walk out it's like it's it's a giant
it's a giant and I I the most I could do
is clear a pathway for when my sister
gets home from work
um and I cleared the pathway and then
five minutes later it's full again and
I'm like
screw this thing screw it man I go
inside I wait till she's about to get
home I do it before it fills up again in
another five minutes and then I left it
for the next day
are you muted bro I was on the phone
with the Romney bro the other day and
you could just hear him just add it bro
with the shovel you know and believe it
or not most Canadians that I call
they're usually just on the phone you
know shoveling you could hear you know
snowplows outside and I called on her
bro silence bro The Good Life
the sky man it makes you ask yourself
why are you living in Canada
it's a good question isn't it someone
else do it no I'm saying it makes you
guys ask yourselves that doesn't it
um
no listen I'll answer that
um in a sec Miller bless Mozzy Buzz for
the summer yeah
someone else writes my own brain you
guys are making me discover God Romi
what do you think
but you know what's even better Allah
God is making you discover him
alhamdulillah
so may Allah continued to use us as just
a vessel bro I mean for a greater cause
I mean we're just instruments man but
the Halal instruments
okay that was that was a good one bro I
love about it he's a funny guy guys
um and then we got shizuki so my
brothers love you guys guys go subscribe
Channel bro he did his shahada with us
about a week ago and he's already going
off bumping out content as a new convert
as a new River to Islam he's posting
videos about some deep stuff bro some
insightful stuff I hit him up the other
day and I I told him exactly how much I
found it valuable so guys come on
there's a lot of blessings in that
channel insha Allah go show him some
love
um okay Rami do you want to answer the
question first why do we uh live in
Canada or why do you live in Canada
until we get 500 viewers
well I mean I don't want to get too
technical but I don't really like the
question because it implies that I had a
choice I was born here alhamdulillah and
I do have a choice you know on where I
want to live but there are some things
keeping me here right now but I do want
to move and I see myself inshallah
moving in the near future to where I
don't know I guess we'll find out
to be continued to be continued to be
continued I had no no choice either
subhanallah I literally just I grew up
in Canada born in Bangladesh someone
commented are you Indian inspired India
I'm not Indian bro
um but I'm from Bengali and I grew up in
in Bangladesh till I was about four
years old maybe
you're so offended bro huh nah bro look
pakistanis bangladeshis but they are all
like uh offended when you call them
Indians yeah do you realize like which
regionally like geographically we're all
in the same area
and we're just men and women but then
these lines in the sand these different
you know countries nationalism political
differences Wars and turmoil and all
this nonsense bro this is we're missing
the greater picture in this bro so
you're saying you're all right with
being called an Indian
Elmo hell no this is why I'm
establishing this very firm guys
please I am not Indian that is like
calling Angel Mexican like how dare you
you know if you're ill-informed that
there's an excuse you know
there's nothing wrong with being Mexican
though yeah nothing nothing wrong with
being blacks again as well bro
um but the main yeah like mixed or
anything like that listen we don't care
where you're from what you are none of
this stuff on the three Muslims it's not
Islamic bro
um now going back to the point I didn't
have a choice we came here when I was
four and I genuinely think my parents
were choosing between Canada and the
states
and I don't think the thing for the
states came in bro
it'd be like that with the United States
unfortunately yeah
I'm like bro at the end of the day and
God's promised no more distracting we're
gonna go right into the emergency
meeting what we're trying to talk about
but last thing is sometimes we gotta ask
ourselves like had it been up to me now
with the knowledge that I have now
obviously I've been why did we move to
Canada we could have moved anywhere else
you know but had we done that I wouldn't
be where I am today
had we done that none of us would be
here the way where we are today the way
we are today and where we are today is
strictly part of the process in terms of
where we're going with our lives so
again no regrets bro alhamdulillah the
problem he said do not say if right
don't say oh man if only my parents
moved here if only I chose to move there
or whatever he said rather say this is
the decree of Allah and Allah
y'all get out of here bro what is this
India fired
that's it bro
I want to go to India man I want to see
the the Taj Mahal
we're done bro we go to India we're done
what do you mean we're done like bro
many countries right now are not smart
for us to go to
India would be one because they don't
really like Muslims bro
they're out here trying to delete
Muslims huh but let's not talk about
that on the stream yeah no we don't want
to talk about it on stream but just
understand one thing that there's many
places in the world that we should not
go to
just because of the way they understand
trust me if anyone understands it it's
me bro
now we're going to be talking about a
couple different things today if you
guys made it this far alhamdulillah
smash that like button
um one of the things that we want to
talk about is or at least this bothered
me enough to voice my my concerns on a
freaking stream clearly to like all
these people is this pathetic state of
Muslims today and non-muslims today when
it comes to these people that are out
here trying to finesse us and using
Islam for views and clout and anything
like that and we we have a soft spot in
our heart because we're good we mean
well but there's a difference between
good intention and good action so we can
talk about that additionally another
thing I wanted to discuss today very
important stuff is what's going on in
Bangladesh bro my country they have just
recently banned nekabs in oh sorry uh
yeah abandoned Nick UPS I have to make
sure I said that right bro because I was
like is it bad is not they've abandoned
nikobs in uh basically for women sisters
to wear in the clubs in universities and
colleges
and just hearing these sisters bro
crying and protesting being like this is
a right that Allah has given us and when
you look at you know Oxford University
Cambridge University all these Western
institutions even they haven't been in
the Cubs and these are kofar countries
why are we Banning the Cubs and many
other things that I want to talk about
there inshallah but do you guys have
anything that you want to touch over why
have they been in the cup in Bangladesh
because they are it's Bangladesh bro
it's this thing that I I call
internalized colonialism I'm sure you've
heard of these these stupid terms like
internalized misogyny and these shaming
tactics they don't really exist right if
a woman refuses to be degenerate today
and she wants to be traditional she
wants to actually fear Allah and live a
more life with Haya she's internalized
misogyny this is what the West uses this
makes no sense but internalized
colonialism is a real thing bro you go
to these countries right now Bangladesh
India bro after the West has basically
invaded them they've left them with this
internalized colonialism role so you
look at Bangladesh you look at India
they use these products like fair and
lovely like there's literally like this
this taboo with people that are darker
skinned bro and like fair skinned
automatically you know equates to like
being better and just being you know
more Pious or being like more attractive
like this makes no sense bro how do you
control the color of your skin bro and
there's many other things about
internalized colonialism that we can
talk about but that's one of the things
you have to appease the colonizer it's
kind of like Stockholm syndrome in a
weird way so now they're like let me
just basically hand span by hand span
arm span by arm span as Hadith mentions
we're going to mimic everything that the
kofar countries do
it was crazy rule it kind of made me
think of like the West right now and how
like I'll explore if you come to the
West everybody's trying to be tan
everyone's trying to be like like that
like Golden Bronze type look
and then if you actually look back to
the first people that inhabited this
land which were the Native Americans
these people are naturally tan
like this this is a natural color and
it's kind of crazy that like the
westerners now are trying to mimic this
color I mean I'm not saying it that's
what it is I'm just saying that it's
just a speculation observation
hmm
what do you think
I love when your voice Cracks by the way
oh just for you bro
um honestly I'm just disappointed to be
completely honest I don't know enough
about Bangladesh the political State
their their situation on what they
believe what they're like their leader
to really make a firm comment
um
but I mean this is something that not
even the West is doing except for like
maybe France and like I don't know other
Europe a few European countries but
hello I just I mean it really puts into
perspective where the priorities lie but
you guys have to understand something
like really important this is something
that the three of us learned very
recently in the class so I won't go too
in depth into it and I've mentioned a
few different types of you know across
different videos but these things are
not random
you know the they didn't just randomly
decide to bend in a club they didn't
just have one like leader decide oh I
want to do this that's it this is
something that was caused by the west
and by liberalism and secularism and
these isms were decided by Europe just
because they were so restricted by the
church that they decided screw religion
we just want to be free so they made
liberalism which lo and behold the whole
point of liberalism is to maximize
individual freedom and with that came
this unconscious unsaid unspoken rule
that
being a religious is freedom and being
religious is being trapped so therefore
we should remove as many religious rules
as possible
and I mean look what they're doing
they've made a religion of their own
they've made an ideology of their own
and now they're imposing it onto the
people so they end up contradicting
themselves long term anyways so I think
it's very just just very sad
uh you mentioned something else that
made me that kind of triggered this
thought in my head that I've been
reflecting on recently I'm going to be
very careful with the words and terms I
use her but I think everyone will be
able to pick up what I'm saying in the
west maybe in you know the early 2000s
they had a goal for democracy for
liberalism for freedom and because of
this goal they invaded our lands our
countries decimated and offed a lot of
people innocent people women and
children as well
for the sake of liberalism
and democracy and freedom
now what are they doing what is what is
their goal what is their war that
they're fighting for the sake of
liberalism and freedom it's it's
alphabetism it is the Alphabet game it
is that whole movement that's all
they're doing politically that is all
they're doing to fight for liberalism so
they went from invading our country for
that for that sake and now they're
masking that whole thing
the whole ideology of being messed with
this war
um basically for the alphabet gang
just take that in
just take that and that is their
political agenda that is their political
fight they went from an actual War
to a an internal political ideological
war with the with their people and this
is why you know they're going to
collapse very soon I promise you very
soon there's going to be a collapse and
there's going to be a huge shift in like
the world order I genuinely believe that
um
well I agree
but uh let's not talk too much about it
yeah I know I know yeah it's not our
place you know like I'm a one we don't
actually like fully know these things
number two uh we do not have the
knowledge like we didn't study these
things nor do we like actively like
go into it and trying to see like what's
going on with this and this like when I
when I tend toes in at the moment with
it
and then number three it just wouldn't
be smart I guess let's be honest this
wouldn't be smart for us to
be going all out with these things
there's better ways to do things
I guess the last thing I'm going to say
regarding this is a lot of people are in
the DMS why do you guys not talk about
these topics why do you guys not talk
about those topics you have a platform
you should talk about these topics guys
what is better make a video about it get
completely deep platform from YouTube
lose the platform and never speak about
anything again
or speak about these things in the most
nuanced manner as possible and stay
within the lines as much as possible be
clear on our stance but then have other
avenues for you guys to see our thoughts
on these things like for example we're
trying to get our website running soon
or rumble or something like that
yeah it's better you know and I've
thought about it many times was like yo
like we should we should say what we
need to say
but it's like I think this is just
this is uh I don't want to say disease
but it's definitely a programming from
the West that we have in our minds where
it's like oh speak your mind speak your
mind Freedom speak freedom of speech but
let's be honest nowhere in the world do
you actually have freedom of speech
you know like even us right now want you
to win the West we think we have freedom
of speech we don't really have freedom
of speech so we have to be very careful
and we have to do things in the most
appropriate way in a um subtle way
you know we bring the truth in a subtle
way and then for those who are actually
trying to seek more
we have other means to give more of the
actual truth and then they can also you
know look up more for themselves it's
not like we are the ones who are it's
it's bestowed upon us to tell you guys
exactly everything that's happening in
the world right now
[Music]
um
so another thing to discuss potentially
today is
what is going on with Afghanistan Ramen
do you think this is appropriate
that we talk about this
I don't know what's going on in
Afghanistan so basically the Taliban
banned women from being in universities
and colleges at the moment what they
have had basically before coming up for
a while is that we are trying to make
the institutions more shittier compliant
not that we're trying to take away their
education and because of that they
basically stopped all women from
attending University in college until
further notice not a permanent ban they
basically just said just until for the
notice they're trying to make emotional
compliant now the West is obviously
going to use this as just propaganda and
they're basically nailing it in and you
see people like Piers Morgan asking
Andrew Tate about it and talking about
how what are your thoughts on that is it
fair is it just you see Western media
using big labels like Taliban bands
women's basic rights and they love this
they love this type of stuff they'll eat
it up
yeah one thing one thing I've learned to
never trust is these big media Outlets
titles ever ever and I'll give one
example one example because this is
something it came across recently and I
think it'll really
um help you know solidify the message
the guardian reported
6 500 people 6 500 migrant workers were
offed due to
Kotor announcing the World Cup
or since Carter announced they're going
to be hosting the World Cup they said
something like that you can go look it
up right now what that seems like is
Qatar having migrant workers build the
stadium cause the death of I mean the
offing of 6 500 migrant workers
what does that number actually show
what does that number actually show that
and they say in the article the number
6500 is the number of Migrant workers
who
left
this Earth no matter how they left no
matter what they were doing
within the country in the last 12 years
since it was decided that's where the
World Cups can be hosted and you see
people tick tock saying oh 6 500 people
whatever that was a lie that's literally
a misleading title so I'm not gonna ever
believe what people are saying but on
this note
it's very important now again we look at
the root if if they are ruling or even
in their own estimation based on the
Sharia
right and I don't know much about them
but if they are they don't go based off
of a liberalism and democracy so to
expect them to act like the West is is
fallacious it's purely ethnocentrism
it's it's it's just an ideal uh an
ideological difference
you might think that's wrong whatever
prove it that's what I'm asking you to
prove that your ideologies right their
ideology is wrong at the root level
otherwise you can complain about XYZ
them if their intention is to only have
the brothers go to school until they can
build sister on these schools and then
segregate I think that's beautiful go
for it doesn't make it easy for them if
their goals are completely ruin and not
have a woman learn Islam at all
or learn educate educate themselves on
anything that's completely unislamic
that's completely wrong and that's not
something as far as another Islam would
allow foreign
opinions but as far as I know that's not
something that Islam actually allows I
had this conversation earlier and even
me and on who were talking about it that
why didn't they ban men from school why
didn't they ban men from going there
what as is as Muslims falling and
practicing Islam we believe that men are
responsible to be providers and
protectives over women so why would it
not make sense that they continue to
basically strive to be the next
Generations of Breadwinners the most
until in the meantime that we can get
our act together with the Sharia
compliance and with the rules and
regulations and code of conduct that we
have firmly rooted in Islam to the best
of our abilities does that not make
sense bro yeah yeah and I mean sorry on
hell you should go inshallah
unless you're gonna say we shouldn't
talk about it then I'm gonna go ahead
and I was gonna say I mean if you think
about our fitra our natural disposition
or just let's look at how people live
the last you know thousands of years it
was always the men going out being the
go-getters being the the Breadwinners
whatever even if it meant they have to
learn something a skill first and then
go work based off that skill it was
always the men doing this this is how
the world has worked this is how men and
women live for thousands of years and
it's something that worked and this is
always something that people naturally
fell into these gender roles and
whatever you want to call it so why
would it be any different in this case
let the men work let the men learn let
the men you know go to school mothers
have very women have very important
roles that men just can't do like be a
mother men cannot be moms men cannot
give birth men cannot breastfeed men are
not as empathetic as women just
literally just based on blood flowing to
certain parts of the brain that make
women more empathetic it's a natural
thing and Allah has created very
beautifully a woman for for with very
beautiful qualities that a man just does
not have us naturally and same thing
with a man Allah has created men with
very beautiful characteristics that
women don't have
like for example the 30 extra muscle
mass we have you know women have wider
hips so they can give birth and makes it
harder for them to move and do physical
labor for men it's easier
so listen you can justify or not just
fire all you want you can go into these
semantics all you want at the end of the
day if you want to make an argument make
it sound go to the root prove whatever
you need to prove but you guys are not
going to be able to prove that oh
liberalism is just the ideology this is
the same style media propaganda that you
saw with Qatar as soon as they said that
we don't want this rainbow nonsense in
our sports teams this is soccer bro
forget even these are our values you're
disrespecting let's keep it at soccer
ball let's keep it at football none of
this rainbow stuff the media ate that up
bro but the problem that they're saying
which is what Ram is alluding to is that
the West
operates in this almost false sense of
we have what's correct we almost
presuppose to be objective truth who
says who
says who because you guys didn't even
believe what you believe in like 10
years ago 15 years ago 20 years ago
and Islam is the only solution that is
objectively grounded in Morality
on Hell bro you were going to say
something earlier
oh what are we doing what are we talking
about right now
I feel like this is like the radio talk
show right now well I mean for people on
audio that's maybe exactly what they
need
yeah that's true
What's um
so did they cut off all education or is
it just like the higher forms of
Education like college I think it's
college and university just until
further notice
okay well I mean the women are still
getting uh basic level
even more than that of knowledge I mean
University if you think about a
university is just setting you up for
the system
it's setting you up to learn a career
path
you know like I don't know
maybe they are doing something different
maybe they're not
if if anyone really take any message
from this I think the most important
thing is that you should never just take
Word of Mouth even if it's like a news
article news organization you should
never just take people's Word of Mouth
you should never just take whatever
people say
um especially when it's going on abroad
and just accept it with open arms
because a lot of the time it's
propaganda a lot of the time it's not
true or it's Amplified or just context
is taken away like imagine I told you
and I think I've used this example a few
times but imagine I told you
um uh so-and-so pushed an old lady
industry actually let me use a better
example uh this actually happened what
I'm telling you now actually happened
a woman
at Walmart an old lady an old lady at
Walmart would not move
from in the middle of the doorway she
was literally just in the middle of the
door she wouldn't move so I pushed her
I swear to God that happened
I did that I pushed an old lady she was
in the middle of the doorway you're
probably thinking you're probably
thinking the Romney's a disgusting guy
cancel I mean she was in one of those
motorized vehicles
and there was a crack in the concrete
before the door so the back wheel got
stuck and she couldn't move so I pushed
the the thing forward so I could gain
traction and she could go
the first version everyone hates me the
second version is like oh okay that's a
nice thing to do just because I gave
more context because a lot of things in
isolation sound really bad
so don't just take word of mouth without
saying the full story as Muslims we're
not supposed to do that either by the
way Allah says
um whenever you're given information
from like a non-not so trust with your
Source here and skeptical about them you
need to verify it Allah Quran
so that's beneficial
may Allah allow us to use the intellect
bro that we've been gifted me I mean
no bro if you guys don't have anything
to say let's address the elephant in the
room which is it's been a long time
coming on the last like 30 plus minutes
and it is about this
almost pathetic simping behavior that I
see and I want to give a very clear
disclaimer me Rami on how we are never
going to judge someone's Islam someone's
sincerity that is between them and Allah
that is not beyond our scope of practice
as human beings of course we can advise
and join good for being evil but it's
not in our place to judge are they
really sincere are they not sincere
that's between the person and Allah
but it goes without saying that there
are insincere YouTubers insincere maybe
non-muslim YouTubers could be Christian
YouTubers could be atheist YouTubers
that have kind of jumped on this
bandwagon of reacting to Islamic content
for views
now mind you another disclaimer because
people are so damn sensitive we are not
talking about the people that are
genuinely seeking knowledge we are not
talking about the people that want to
learn about Islam we are talking about
the people that are genuinely reacting
to sensationalized things you know
non-muslim reacts to this and that which
is fine but then they actually never
make the intention to do it for the sake
of Allah or for themselves to learn this
knowledge but rather super chats rather
let me make a lot of money with YouTube
views let me get clout let me get status
this is a very fast way to grow because
let's be honest The Tao scene is popping
you see videos in Minecraft you see
video game tutorials and things that I
used to see these were very high viewed
Avenues and niches but when you look at
Islamic channels Muslim channels they're
really blowing up they're really popping
off and a lot of these people use this
for personal gain but if only they knew
that they're trading something else
which is way more important now I want
to know what you guys think before I go
a little bit deeper into the inshallah
two-sided coin
on one side
you see it as like
oh well
you know what they may be doing it for
views and for money and all this but
they could potentially be guided from
this Allah knows and we do not but then
on the other side there's the fact that
they are doing this for money or for
views and Allah knows best and at that
point it's like you are
you're essentially trying to use the
religion you're trying to sell it
for a small piece of Dunya which I mean
it's even said about that in the Quran
so again it's a it's a two-sided coin
mm-hmm what about you bro
um
I don't know I think I have a little
more chill of an opinion about this um I
don't really have a problem like if
people want to use Islam for views in
the sense that they're reacting to like
our videos and saying wow that's great
or reacting to many prophets one message
your Muhammad hijab and saying wow
that's amazing I didn't know that go for
it I personally even if you have the
wrong intention I personally don't care
because all they're doing is spreading
the two the percent whether they like it
or know it or not even if they have a
bad intention and Allah may just be
using them to guide any of their viewers
anyone maybe their normal some viewers
that see their Channel and they even if
the viewer ends up hating Islam later or
not if you're the Creator and the paying
for you later yeah there could be
viewers that watch and say well actually
I agree with this stuff I think it's I'm
sure Allah guides them because that all
boils down to Allah who he wills at the
end of the day you have people even like
you know after the the passing of the
process early on that would fabricate a
Hadith about the process and I'm going
to use the Deen to their advantage in
Advantage but they was laid up straight
up lie you know and Allah talks about
people in the Quran who write this
scripture with their own hand and
they're just basically selling it for a
little bit in this world and basically a
punishment Allah will deal with these
people right Allah never tells us go do
this to them go do that to them Allah
tells us in the Quran spread the truth
of Islam speak the truth even if it's
against yourself or the wealthy or
whatever Allah says to um obviously you
know if you don't know like I mentioned
with information is coming from if you
don't know if it's authentic justify it
make sure that it is true and um many
other things that show us how to go
about this but never does Allah say you
know you know throw these people away or
whatever because it's possible that
people accept Islam for worldly Reasons
I'm talking about except actually saying
the except Islam for worldly reasons and
then later action enters their heart
okay so I'm gonna do my best to be as
concise as possible I 100 agree with you
bro I can see to your point and I agree
that at the end of the day there could
be a Creator let's say that's making
Islamic content and they might be
insincere they don't care about they
don't care about sincerity in Islam but
people find Islam through these videos I
agree with you 100 that it's very
beneficial
but I'm more alluding to the fact that
this pathetic simpish behavior that I
see in a lot of Muslims they are
donating thousands and thousands of
dollars in super chats to these channels
that have been researching Islam for 10
years five years making videos and then
they're still like why I still won't
convert to it like they're overtly I'm
not gonna name any names now they're
overtly definitely disobedient and
arrogant role and these people there's
kids dying in Syria in Lebanon and it
breaks my heart seeing all these ads and
campaigns and we should all be giving
sadaka but instead this is where we're
giving our money to
bro is this is this what Allah has put
us here with the gift and blessing of
Islam for bro
yeah I um I I agree with that point as
well and there have been cases that I've
heard of where people either accept
Islam or talk a lot about Islam and then
start some kind of donation or charity
or GoFundMe and they raise a lot of
money and then instantly change after
they get x amount of money Allah you
know Allah these people I don't think we
should be donating to these people like
that just because we're looking into
Islam
um but at the same time I'm not I'm from
that point right I'm not I'm not giving
any specifications where you can do that
I don't think we should donate to these
people like for these reasons
um on the sub note I've spoken to you
know these people before and one person
in particular
um who did all those things you know
reviewed Islam and talked about this and
that and made videos why I'm not Muslim
I've spoken to one of those people very
recently
um uh actually they reached out to me
about this
um and I've been discussing with them
you know evidence of Islam and things
more in depth because you know a lot of
these people they see surface level
things on you know online they don't
actually get to the deep understanding
of Islam maybe some of the information
they heard is actually wrong you know
they're not actually studying Islam
properly not going to Scholars they're
not really getting proper answers and I
think that's that's why this person
reached out to me and based on my
conversation with them I could see that
um so every case is particular but I
agree with your point that we shouldn't
just be basically throwing money in
super chats of these people because
we're looking into Islam it would be
much better to like go to like you know
Islam net or Muhammad hijab or sapiens
Institute or I3 Institute where people
are doing good work for the sake of
Allah they are Muslim they're bringing
more Muslims to Islam they're teaching
Muslims how to give Dao to bring more
people to Islam donate to them donate to
the people of of Syria and Yemen like
you mentioned instead is definitely much
much better there's more hair in
donating two Muslim content creators
that are actually correct trying to have
a sincere intention trying to put
forward the message of the prophecy
Islam and of Islam because these people
know what they're doing with their views
with their influence with their reach
and inshallah Their audience and
intention is sincere may Allah protect
from that
um from not having it sincere I mean but
if it's sincere then I think it's much
more fruitful than just donating to
someone that's just watching and
reciting reacting to the Quran which is
nothing wrong by the way but I'm talking
about the level of I guess almost the
simpish behavior to the point where we
need validation from these people
and this brings me to another sub point
and there's that people are looking at
non-muslim Celebrities influencers
people that are openly disrespecting
Islam like Jordan Peterson and just
looking for a crumb bro just crumbs of
validation
please please show me Islam is correct
show me that you know you actually
believe in Islam you actually see it too
so have you guys experienced anything
with that in the YouTube scene that
people are almost idolizing these people
and just almost needing them to validate
Islam
I think it's it's just been a huge trend
for the last like two decades
um there are some cases where I think
it's a bit valid like with Keith Moore
who is an um embryology like specialist
and he was speaking about how the Quran
gets like the embryological development
of the feet is correct I think that has
grounds and that's fair because he's a
professional but not because he's a
non-muslim obviously I think there was
an aspect where people are like you know
look at this non-muslim who must be
unbiased because he's not a Muslim and
he's saying this it must be true I I
don't think that we should use people's
people being a Muslim or not being a
Muslim as grounds for whether we should
believe them or not whether they're
unbiased or not because at the end of
the day you would not know something
like that you could have a Muslim that
is unbiased like genuinely I believe I'm
a Muslim who's unbiased that literally
based on the evidence I have seen
believe Islam is the truth right but
you'll have people that look at me and
others and will say well he's a Muslim
obviously he's going to preach Islam and
he was born into it whatever so I think
likewise just because someone's not a
Muslim doesn't mean we should go be like
oh my God look at them they're praising
Islam this is such a big victory like um
Andrew Tay before I became a Muslim
people were idolizing him and and trying
to say like oh my god look the top G
said this about Islam and you know
alhamdulillah is a Muslim
which means he's more valid now
alhamdulillah
um but before Yanni like who cares like
he's a non-muslim or not just him or the
non-muslim speaking about Sam positively
why do you need to you know praise these
people above and beyond you know that is
online and what they say about Islam
hmm
knows very well said bro I'm about it I
don't know what about you
mommy said it perfectly bro perfect
there's a comment here um yeah sorry
really quickly sure um I can't find it
but uh someone mentioned you know the
Muslims here
uh the way the Muslims sent over Jordan
Peterson who turned out to be blown
Zionist was truly pathetic bro don't say
the Z word now come on
um
leave me alone man leave me alone but um
yeah like that's that's very true he
spoke to Mohammed a job once twice and
everyone's like oh my god look he's
open-minded he's speaking he's talking
he's having a conversation
um when he listens to the conversation
you've noticed that he's very unfair in
his and when he speaks about Islam or
even when he listens to Islam when he
Converses about stem he has all these
crazy questions like what do you mean
when you ask do you believe in god what
does that mean it's like bro that's such
a crazy question like yes Define what
you mean by God
maybe Define belief but like relax like
that's it's such a straightforward
question don't beat around the bush and
then he straight up
brought the Prime Minister President or
whatever of a very specific nation in
the Middle East thus not a Muslim or
Arab nation and um completely
let him spew nonsensical garbage
to diligent delegitimize the Palestinian
struggle
that's that's a big L that's I think the
Muslim Community part of them in that
way it took and mailables you know
speakers like
who is actively dissecting these and
speaking out against these things like
Jordan Peterson yeah Muhammad as well
you know he didn't just speak with him
he he made a reputation recent as well
someone commented is this back budding
how was his back budding we're not
naming any of these YouTubers that are
using these and I gave the biggest
disclaimer possible about how we are not
here to judge people's sincerity but we
are making a general point that there's
better uses for investment in terms of
energy money and people that need it way
more
yeah can we even backbone against
non-muslims I don't even think that's a
thing I don't know and also there's a
general principle if you don't name the
names typewriting is something like
overall I don't think it should just
apply it anymore
yeah I'm talking about you know in terms
of being punished by Allah yeah like a
fake thing yeah I don't know but what I
do know is in general when it comes to
back budding if you don't say the name
and you don't describe who it is then
you make a point but again no no fake
answers bro we're not qualified so first
Super Chat
um from Brother AJ
oh could you beat it up bro
uh thank you Brothers for streaming you
guys have helped me get close to my Dean
and made me realize that there's nothing
that there's nothing with I'm assuming
he meant nothing wrong with being a
masculine man may Allah guide in the
right direction help us be better Allah
I mean
um again it was Allah who guided us and
guided you maybe Allah use other people
to guide us and maybe Allah use us to
guide you but all good is from Allah
thank you
I can also make content in Spanish
there's a lot of ignorance and
misinformation about Islam in Latin
America I only met Muslims for the first
time when I moved to Canada and my view
really changed it's a good question
thank you
man's gonna be like if Allah Wills nah
it's not that man
it's just my Spanish is not perfect
it's um it is my native tongue but
I don't practice as much as I should
and the fact that I'm learning other
languages as well kind of doesn't help
so
I could try I could definitely try but
it would be very butchered Spanish
and be more like Spanglish
all right all right subhanallah
she should name himself sheath after
sheath
Angel if you Wills if he wants to but
there's no obligation changing your name
unless from what I remember is it
specifically Haram or like a forbidden
name you know
all right so I'm gonna try to have a lot
of Grace subhanallah because
alhamdulillah we came a long way after
getting to you know two years into
YouTube alhamdulillah like two or three
weeks ago and our approach that we have
now has a lot more other than the
approach that we had before and the
approach that a lot of men and I want to
make this point before we address this
this uh ridiculous comment is too many
people are coming into it with this
almost triggered and aggressive
mentality and I understand that we have
Hada for the Deen and to defend the
prophet saws this is something that is
very natural in a very sound fitra for
us to do as men and women but we must
understand that a lot of these people
genuinely lack education this person if
they knew the truth about the prophet
saws they would not be saying what they
are saying right now even look at the
the name it says Sam the Trinity loving
devil so it could be a Christian but
again I can't even accuse that bro
because that would be no better than
this other person right now that's
accusing the prophet saws now when it
comes to this this overarching principle
about you know just genuinely
um being aggressive towards people it's
kind of like a knee-jerk reaction we do
these things without thinking so if
someone insults the prophet or insults
Islam
sure it's not okay we have to defend a
demon but how do you do it if you fight
or wrong with a with another wrong and
you basically come into it like you know
what like you're out here saying this
screw you this and you get physical or
even you know do something else so Rami
talked about this before that's not
productive bro No One's Gonna Learn
anything
so in an academic answer as much as I
can give you there's a YouTuber by the
name of Full Metal theist now Miller
blessed full metal thieves but he makes
a lot of refutation videos so to the Sam
the Trinity brother or sister if you're
genuinely sincere and it bothers you
that you think that the prophet peace be
upon him was this a stuck for Allah
which he wasn't then please watch this
video if you're really sincere if you're
not sincere continue posting these
ridiculous comments on different videos
and at the end we'll see what happens
bro when it's all said and done
yeah also some note if you are a
Christian which I can't I really can't
tell by your name um if you are a
Christian read numbers 31 18.
um you you'll find that um
whatever your perception of Islam is
what's in the Old Testament is a lot
worse
hmm
cool and we'll leave it at that now we
do get a lot of these trolls many
comments many people get these but
Romney do you want to address this
because they are spreading a lot of
misguard and some fidma
Islam is the truth why did it say when
you kill an unbelievable you'll go to
paradise and get 72 versions where can
you give me the quote please
I shouldn't have read that word but I
mean yeah where did you find it finding
the Quran please Habibi please please
um hello all right cool
no into other things now that we're done
those things
on Homan me and Rami have been doing an
awful lot of talking what do you think
what's on your mind
I don't know actually I didn't think I
didn't actually know what we're going to
get into today
but it's generally generously has felt
like a uh talk show like a radio talk
show
and um I think it's funny that I'm over
here saying oh we shouldn't be talking
about these things and then
y'all like carry on to like talk about
something that they're doing in Afghan
I genuinely wasn't up I'm sorry I was
reading comments what did you say it's
all good bro
Afghanistan and I was like oh no what no
no it's listen at the end of the day
these conversations that we have every
now and then or get from Allah because
they they show us that maybe off camera
we should decide you know what is good
what is not really renew and revise all
these things too because as the platform
gets bigger bro the the risk involved
the risk involved in our Channel
increases getting a d platform so this
is also a message to content creators
that have influenced uh in Instagram
tick tock tick tock is the worst by the
way you know they'll they banned SQ so
many times
um they were Black Hebrew Israelites
that stepped on Quran
um and and stepped on them stomped on
them defiled them dehumanized them in
like the most worst mannered way
possible all SQ did was make a video
saying please please stop like why are
you doing this why are you doing this
the holy book like please stop
and then sq's video got removed as Q's
Channel got completely taken down it's
not insane
that's actually not insane
that's because it's about tick tock
you gotta understand why was Tick Tock
made damn here I am about to say
something where I'm like no we shouldn't
be talking about these things listen if
y'all want to know why tiktok was made
go look on Google for yourselves or go
on our website once we have everything
and we'll be talking more and that's
about that inshallah inshallah let's
leave it at that then
um comment from the same person Slavic
drill writes this
uh look at Europe we never had problems
bro
I'm just saying wait what I'm saying
don't say the t word when it comes bro
oh okay uh look at Europe uh we never
had pounds only since Muslims came to
Europe we got hundreds of Muslims tea
attacks
um what's your opinion on this well
first and foremost that's actually not
true the exact opposite is true and let
me explain go look at the Dark Ages in
Europe you'll find that none of the like
the roads were paved there was a lot of
disease in this and famine going around
it was a horrible life people were
oppressed for a very long time under the
Catholic church in Europe and it was
only through Wars and battles fought
against the Muslims that they saw
Muslims are scientifically
mathematically technologically advanced
while we have none of those advancements
because the church does not allow us to
advance in that way based on whatever
rules they made up with the time
but the Muslims have the best of both
the world they're religious and they
have these things and then over time
they translated it's literally called a
translational period translated a bunch
of books from philosophy to religion to
um law and legislation to math to
science all these different categories
from Arabic into Latin studied it
progressed because of the Muslim Head
Start that they were given and then
eventually threw away all religion put
Christianity Islam everything in the
same boat as being horrible because all
religion is bad apparently and then went
on this temper tantrum invaded the
Middle East did horrible things there
ruined our way of life split our Nations
or our nation one big nation into little
places on the map and cause horrible
political distress in the Middle East so
there's a little history lesson for you
you can verify every single thing I said
um please educate yourself before you
comment such a thing if you are sincere
don't take it the wrong way but there's
a lot of information misinformation
going on
yeah we got to remember that these uh T
attacks that this
this guy had mentioned there
these can be found everywhere
in every country it's not just
um so-called Muslims that are supposed
to be doing this
like you look in
I'll give some like random country we'll
say this country is called Pangea just
for safety precautions and you guys know
how it is right
was these countries called Pangea
they're going to have someone so T
attacks there
like
this is me trying to like keep it
uh
it's so hard not saying things man
it sucks that everything's so like
sensitive and
everything can be triggered and we're
pretty much being watched and listened
to at all times
not just by like people like viewers but
I'm saying like an actual algorithm and
actual like you know people who control
everything
as their freedom of speech bro
#muzzy Buzz writes
I'm a person looking for material in
Spanish check out Islam in Spanish with
mujahid Fletcher for the great Trinity
debunking check out Muslim metaphysician
you can get the um in Spanish
yes that is true that's true
[Music]
boys anything else before we wrap up
this one
is does anyone have any questions
a little bit of a q a inshallah
oh god oh no this is gonna be uh
it's gonna start blowing up now there's
too many
what
questions
okay first one this one
are you doing a pod with Vlad and you
you again or you again I don't know who
they are no me either if Allah was I
think they're people I think they're
people they might be people in the
actual comments oh look at this
I have many questions that I want to
convert um
listen I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you
something right now
um we don't have too long we're probably
gonna wrap this up in like you know 10
15 minutes max but Ernest if you would
like to be a part of the stream
Insha'Allah please
let us know
you know DMS on Instagram at the three
Muslims we could talk about this you
don't have to turn on your video if you
don't want to turn on your video
inshallah
keep the audio only and we can just
discuss this Insha'Allah let me know
we'd love to talk about this because
there's more hair in other people
sitting in on these conversations too
we could change your voice as well
we're gonna do a pre-recorded and change
your voice
will you guys ever make history
oh another one
um it's Hijra mandatory so this is a
very vast question because the scholars
have a difference of opinion on when
Hijra is mandatory the the state that
makes hedgero mandatory the state we're
in now and if Hijra is mandatory now
from one country to another like for
example from like Canada to another
country Scholars have a difference of
opinion best thing I could suggest is go
to a scholar local to you ask for the
opinion on this someone who studied
generally speaking Hijra is obligatory
and it's obligatory to go from a a cafe
country a disbelieving country a
non-muslim country to a believe in
country basically a country where there
is Islam that's all I'm going to say on
it as general as possible Scholars have
you know specifics yeah I agree and I'll
add two points
um let's use our limited understanding
that Allah has given us and just think
for a second
in a remember the thing you said on the
podcast with Sony
and you were saying how like yeah yeah
you were talking about
um the capitalistic and liberalistic
ideas
like he wanted um Financial Freedom and
he wanted to
we'll see when do you want like uh teach
his kids at home like homeschool his
kids or something like this
like you want the freedom to do this
or something like this huh uh or freedom
of speech I think you even said
but you said that he has that and like
what's the coincidence that these match
like the society that you live in their
isms
so if you think about this then that
means that it's true that we are a
direct result of our environment nature
versus nature nature versus nurture
nature is the environment and if you
live in a far country well then you are
directly influenced and affected by like
four ideologies whether you are like on
Dean like doing your part like us us
right here we live in the West
but we are affected by these ideologies
whether we want to admit it or not it
affects us psychologically you know
subconsciously as well we might have
blocks that we don't even know about
until we actually go to lands that are
Muslim lands like when I was in Thailand
and I was going in the Masjid every
single day and I was barely barely
exposed to
um any Western stuff like I know
Thailand is not Muslim by any means but
I definitely felt closer to Allah I
definitely feel something different and
then when I went to Egypt I felt the
same thing over there more and more in
depth because it's an actual Muslim land
there's like Muslims everywhere
so it makes you really think like okay
well what's actually
uh affecting me right now in terms of
like these blocks right that's number
one
and then number two is like if we
understand the Hadith that are mentioned
of the you know the end times and when
the digital comes like you should be in
in Mecca Medina uh the holy lands yeah
if we understand this and we understand
like how all the mind of science have
pretty much
come true and all the minor signs coming
true is one of the signs that like we're
already near the end times if we if we
can see that and we understand that we
are new in the end times and why would
you want to stay
in Oklahoma
like what is your reason for wanting to
stay in a good father that's what you
got to ask yourself I'm not here to like
question any of you guys this is for you
ask yourself these questions and then uh
S talks with Sheikh my Romney said but
use your intellect as well like think
about these things
hmm
uh Z2 Zed you says I converted seven
years ago and they had me do it
immediately and then later at Isha
because you never know when the time of
death will come you're talking about
praying Salah or
foreign
with the stream yard link once you get
the stream your link please hop on ASAP
you don't need to sign up no downloads
let's get it done inshallah
meet us what is the hajjud
Salah is a Salah that's done at night
time it's when you basically sleep and
you wake up for the sake of praying at
night to Allah
um
I believe the best time to pray to 100
is in the last third of the night
and there's a Hadith that specifies uh
that in what Allah you know does during
that time
anything you guys want to add
um is the best thing
very difficult
but the best thing
yeah yeah Scholars say that at the time
of the hadrid is like the arrow that
never misses
so if you want something you need
something praying to hajjud every night
for it is the best way to um to get your
daughter answered now that doesn't mean
you're gonna get anything you ask for
because maybe what you're asking for is
not good uh whether you know it or not
Allah Knows Best
how do you declare which sources of
information online are credible or not
well you have to go to what their
sources are you know not every internet
is a source in and of itself they will
have their reasons for saying what they
say read the article firstly see if all
the information they're presenting
themselves line up
um and then see what they reference you
know if I write an article on some
medical finding and I don't Source
anyone then you shouldn't take it
because I'm where am I getting my
information from am I the scientist the
author scientist the author of the
medical expert no okay so where do they
get it from if they do Source it you
know this um this um article from done
from this uh person with a master's
degree this medical expert whatever okay
go read what they wrote about it if you
know there's an experiment that's done
and Papers written on it that were peer
reviewed in that stuff go read those and
if you find the information is accurate
and lines up then it should be good
um that's basically the best General
explanation I can give
foreign
no comment
hold up bro
hmm go back for a second I unstarted but
it basically asked is Dubai worth man I
just want to see it on the screen I knew
what the question was it's gone bro yeah
yeah
we we're not going to speak on any place
in specific
um again this is between you and Allah
because when you make history for the
sake of Allah
so you look you can look at places and
you could say okay this place has these
pros and these cons and you can
you know distinguish which one you'd
rather be in but at the end you pray
and Allah will guide you the rest of the
way it's not up to us to tell you where
to go
Ernest bro are you coming no DM yet I
don't know what's going on inshallah
we're gonna have to wrap up soon I
don't know what is going on inshallah
there's no Twitter mention no DM nothing
maybe he thinks we're like telling him
for like the next time
oh no bro right now if you want to do it
right now inshallah we shouldn't delay
these things you can ask us the
questions inshallah if not definitely we
can plan it anytime bro what was here
okay next question
uh question honestly I converts years
ago but I don't feel any I don't feel
different anything I could do to get me
closer to Islam well the first thing you
have to do is look at your life is your
life in Islamic life is your has your
life changed at all since you accepted
Islam
um because if you go from a life of not
being a Muslim to being a Muslim things
need to change sometimes where you work
sometimes what you eat sometimes you
hang around the things you consume and I
don't just mean like what you eat
consume but the information you're
getting and the you know the different
entertainment you're consuming praying
Salah fasting all these things change so
if you you're doing all these things and
nothing changed I don't think that's
really possible to be honest I think
that's actually a contradiction but
regarding this
um if you're talking about what you feel
inside your heart I don't think you've
learned Islam deep enough I think you
need to spend more time reading the
Quran I think you need to spend more
time learning under Scholars and under
teachers you know deeply about Islam the
belief in Allah belief in Islam with the
process the life he lived
and and all that stuff and you will find
that you have more Iman and you will
find that you're closer to Allah
inshallah the place you live too
you forgot that
the place you live I can have a big
impact yeah
yeah
um I'll also say like to add on to your
point
is if we spend the entire day stimulated
and distracting ourselves with
electronics and stuff like this I found
it very difficult to get close to Allah
so
you know maybe look at your life and see
you know if you're spending all your
time on electronics you know distracting
yourself and all that or if you live a
very simple life
hmm
all right Honest got you
Asura nine five then off the the kaffar
and the non-believers where we find them
capture them and besiege them and lie
and wait for them in each and every
Ambush okay or if we're gonna play this
game let me go to the Surah and I'll
read the verses after and it'll clear it
up for you so you're you're immuted bro
I wanna bro I'm what is the historical
context of when this verse was revealed
let's let's look it up bro let's let's
do some homework guys we're not we're
not shy of anything
the truth will prevail
um Adam writes I have a question is this
Haram see we're not qualified to get
[ __ ] was on this but the majority of
Scholars conclude the most correct valid
opinion is that it is Haram unless in
very specific cases such as let's say
you are literally about a volunteers you
know like if there's like no other way
you've tried everything Bro you've tried
like I'm talking fasting and doing
everything to lower your your drive and
there's just nothing that's working bro
then there is one opinion that in those
dire circumstances if you're literally
going to find those in otherwise then
yes it is permissible uh but office
obviously watching anything is under any
circumstances never a permissible growth
yeah
it's tough man bro someone wrote this I
think I think you guys misspelled on oh
Fire and Fire is the manniest man here
um I want to go back to that comment
um about the Surah 9-5 because I saw he
put Surah it looks like he copied and
pasted from like Wiki slime or something
because it's like one after the other
um Surah 456 uh
all it says that surely those who reject
our signs we will cast them into the
fire it's like basically allow us they
will punish the disbelievers like Allah
himself so I don't see why that's a
problem
um but for Surah 9 Allah if you read the
story you'll see that it specifically
talks about there are people who broke
the peace treaty now I don't know what
happens with for example if someone
breaks the peace treaty with America and
what you think would happen then but if
you would have a problem with this then
you surely must have a problem with that
because when someone breaks the peace
treaty with you they're engaging in an
act of war and in many cases they
actually attempted the life of the
Prophet or sahaba right so if you read
read from verse one all of you read from
verse one two verse 9 and afterwards
maybe verse 20 21 you'll see the full
context read what Ben Cathedral wrote
about it that talk about that time they
were in a state of War
you'll you it's very easy to cherry pick
verses I can also cherry pick a verse
and Surah 8 Allah says after one of
these verses uh he says if they incline
towards peace then also incline towards
peace I can I can show you that and say
well surely Islam must be a religion of
Peace because it's saying if they even
inclined towards it you should also
incline towards it which shows that the
base level islamically is peace so
I know the times a war but how can you
believe in a religion that tells you do
things like that well I mean how can you
believe let me finish reading the thing
my butt and which came hundreds of years
after Judaism Christianity Islam is fake
you need to know this okay but firstly
if you are not a Jew
if you're a Christian for example you've
also disproven Christianity because they
came after Judaism if you are not
then this is this is no argument to say
that stem is false because let's say for
example I actually think how can you
believe in a religion that says
something like if you're a slap turn the
other cheek because you would be
eradicated on the first day one group
that's violent that doesn't like people
to eradicate all of you and you can't
even fight back so where Islam is a
beautiful religion because if you
inclined towards peace we will incline
towards peace but if you come and attack
us we're going to defend ourselves if
you break your peace treaty with us
bring it yeah we're gonna go to work
that's life that's life that's that's
the nation civilization governmental
life that's how things are and that's
not ideally it wouldn't be like that but
we don't live in an ideal real world we
live in the real world so when you see
one a country attack another do you
expect them to be so peaceful they're
like yeah come stomp on my face
I don't think you would do the same if
someone came and attacked you so
now you know inshallah
okay the next one I want inshallah on
how to uh ask it so brother sister is
meditation Haram uh because I was told
that it imitates the disbelievers bro so
again no fake answer but what are your
thoughts on it
I mean
there are certain styles of meditation
which definitely
definitely a Haram
but meditation in and of itself like the
simplest simplest form
it's just focus
that's it it's like attention span like
when you meditate they tell you oh focus
on your breathing and when your thoughts
go to something else you just bring it
back to your breathing
if you've listened to a recitation
and you're listening to the recitation
and your thoughts wander off but then
you bring your thoughts back to the
recitation is that not the same thing
if you were making Dua and as you're
making Dua your thoughts wander and you
start thinking about something else but
you bring your thoughts back to the Dua
is that not the same thing
so in that sense I'm not a scholar so I
can't say what is Haram or halad but in
that sense it doesn't there's no
difference but again if you actually
look
into meditation there are certain forms
of meditation which are
for sure for sure
and bro at the end of the default the
default silk when it comes to matters
non-ibada is that everything is halal
and unless it's specifically mentioned
to be out on and there's nothing
mentioning for this to be Haram now if
you're doing weird types of meditation
that are actively involved in things
that are Haram or lead to that it's a
different story if you believe that
meditation is a replacement for Salah
that's a different story
but just thinking and reflecting and
getting some mental Clarity I don't know
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that but please consult this call
um someone else
I have a question for Romney and angel
I'm trying I'm gonna answer bro it's
called the five Gospels
um but sure if you want it all mean and
uh on how to answer guys you can you can
tell
they need it for me bro I've never like
I'd say on the count of three
nah go ahead bro you say you're the one
that's like always talking about it it's
in your house it's actually probably
right next to you I I moved everything
to the bookcase outside because it was
cluttered here but uh I got you I I
looked unfortunately it wasn't but yeah
it's called the five gospels by the
Jesus seminar
as long as they mention my name in that
bro I don't know isn't prayer a form of
meditation no there are two separate
things
Salah is active worship to Allah
meditation is optional
it's not worship can it be an act of
worship with the right intention that's
not up to me to gauge but it's not the
same again we're not Scholars
also we have to be we have to Define
what we mean like for this is a good
comment meditation about saying um or
whatever
Hindu god names uh and words
so I mean it depends on what you mean
when you say meditation because words
can mean different things if you just
literally mean you sit and because the
process in a way because he meditated he
went to the the cave and he went he sat
and he reflected and he pondered and so
on that's you know that's completely
Halal process and that's when he
received from Allah for the first time
so it's not a problem I want to bring it
back to this uh Slavic drill guy
um
yeah he said but Chris I can tell he's a
Christian I said but Christianity is
basically the same as Judaism the only
difference is with the Trinity that is
the literally literally the opposite
because if you go and ask the Jews the
same question if they're closer to Islam
or to to Christianity they will all tell
you we're closer to Islam theologically
in terms of their practice at literally
every Avenue
Jesus came and said you know according
to the the New Testament that he came to
fulfill the law not to abolish it and
then Paul came and basically abolished
the law you don't have to not eat pork
you don't have to stay away from wine
you can do basically whatever you want
just believe Jesus died for your sins
that's nowhere in the Old Testament and
if you are worried about these verses in
the Quran that you're taking out of
context read First Samuels 15 3. it says
off he literally says off men women
children sheep cattle camels and donkeys
what did the animals do
I don't know go ask the author of the
Old Testament I don't know go read
um
uh what's it called numbers 31 18. it
says off all the all the men and the
older women that have lied with men and
say for yourself they're young girls and
that word that's used in Hebrew
referring to Young every other time that
word is used is talking about children
so listen if if I think you want to take
this claim back that Christian and
Judaism is the same thing because if
that's true then you have you know
really really big problems to deal with
and with all do I don't mean this rude
but with all due respect you should not
go around berating and lying about
taking things out of context and other
religions When You Believe in a book
that says these things
he hasn't even said that he's Christian
yet
but yeah but he made the the he doesn't
have to be Allah but he made the
comparison Christian Judaism the same
thing yeah this is a troll bro just we
just there's no there's nothing bro
after this comment
the problem with the Muslim is that
you'd tell all others that their
religion isn't true leave the okay I
mean if you're just gonna generalize
like that whatever man but bro
no worries inshallah have a good life
man see you in the afterlife bro enough
said
three more and then inshallah we will
wrap this up what happened to Ernest
Ernest will reach us next time he is
working right now guys
so question is is wasting time on games
for example whether PC or mobile is
something that is hated or Haram
um
yeah I've I've heard okay first and
foremost if
anything that leads to Haram is Haram so
if you are so addicted to games that it
makes you constantly miss your Salah
then I'm not giving any ruling but from
what I've heard some Scholars say that
it is actually hard on for you to play
unless you can get yourself to get off
at a time and prioritize just a lot
first and foremost so that's the most
General answer I could give
um but ask a scholar
yeah like the the thing that I've seen
with it is uh
as long as like you said it's not
taking you away from this Allah as long
as it doesn't have anything that's
explicitly Haram in it then supposedly
like from what I heard it's permissible
but then at the same time like let's say
you spend an hour playing video games
let's see there's nothing into this
Haram that so you still go and pray it's
like that's an hour that
you probably didn't have Allah's name on
your tongue or in your mind
you know like there was no mention of
Allah whatsoever so it's like you you
you're allowing yourself to be an hour
without that which think about what
happens in idle time
you know I'm playing video games you
might think you're doing something but
that's out of time for sure
oh hold on hold on hold on let me stop
for a second he says he keeps mentioning
Europe Europe
uh why don't you tell anything about
this why
bro what about
um
what about America
what about America before it became
America when it was uh just Native
Americans
and then the uh
the the Spaniards they were European at
the time they came over there and then
that's basically like tea attacks on
them is it not
they took their lands they uh did some
atrocious things to the people off the
people
and uh well now you have now you have
the West
so what about that what about that you
don't you don't see the uh the people in
the west saying that the uh the
Europeans are the teas
come on yeah and also that's right uh
you're absolutely right what he's saying
doesn't even make sense because it's not
accurate you're basically saying that
there are all these tea attacks that are
coming from Muslims in Europe that's not
true look at what the white Christian
supremacists did to the the the church
in uh I believe in Norway Christ Church
what about them what about the the white
people that get in their cars or
whatever Muslim families what about them
the Christians who do this why are you
not can why are you not isolating these
people and saying what's wrong with you
white people what's wrong with you white
supremacist Christians why are you guys
doing this you're a complete hypocrite
and listen I want you to First
acknowledge the contribution the Muslims
made to Europe yes the contributions
Muslim made to Europe and then we will
um we will entertain this conversation
with you if not we're not going to
answer any of your garbage anymore man
really right
I don't even we're done bro we're done
this comment no one's none of us are
going to read this up but if you guys
are visually watching this anyone on
Spotify Apple podcast uh if you hope
you're on YouTube but this is facts bro
bro you don't see us not generalizing on
every white person or every American no
guys there's too much hate in the world
and the only solution is Islam
the first thing to literally take out
racism bro in terms of legislative
Authority in religious text
unheard of bro
yeah the uh the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam even said to
uh that you should always speak the
truth even if it uh hurts the other
people's feelings even if it's bitter
so we saw you hurt your feelings bro but
it is what it is man
you have to ask yourself why does it
hurt you so much
why does it make you so mad yeah
for real bro
yeah
all right last question
I'm gonna pick a good one and shot but
and then I'm gonna call you uh on home
I'm gonna continue to talk on business
inshallah
uh we got Master rights what what type
of name is that okay I play video games
while listening to nasheeds
you better start doing something else
instead of playing video games the hell
are you playing video games for man
like you should be
learning some new skill
practicing some new skill
or literally mastering like sharpening
your iron on one of the skills that you
already had
like come on man if you're a boy
okay like it's understandable and it's
kind of acceptable because you're a boy
still but you're gonna be a man at some
point so they might as well start
learning the skills now so then when you
are man you know when you grow into a
man you are like ahead of the game
you know don't make the mistake of
saying oh I can I can do the uh
the adult stuff once I'm an adult
because then once you're an adult you're
already late
um okay one actual Super Chat so
um I believe you're referring to when we
say in a in Italian
um obviously not because it's part of
our Salah
um actually someone asked the same David
would actually be the same point in
debate with Mohamed hijab and if you saw
that then you know that he said he
mentioned that the Angels actually
delivers the Salam to the process so we
don't believe that the process that can
hear us or anything like that that would
be sure
hmm
no as well said bro
um another one from Starbucks bro this
is stupid uh I will be the last one to
answer this I want you guys to go first
man
I'll go I'll go first I know it's gonna
be the lowest I've my Max has been a
plate alhamdulillah
bro that's that's a play more than 99 of
the universe bro most of the people
what about you
I haven't
dude I don't bench for one I only do uh
dumbbells but when I last did a Max I
was back in like I think it was either
11th grade or 12th grade
and um no no it was 11th grade it was
11th grade
and I think I weighed 150 pounds at the
time I was just starting to bulk up from
116.
and at 150 I could do 225 so I'm just
two plates truth be told I've actually
never done one rep max for benching
um I think the reason being is just me
personally I don't really go for one
remarks training I find it extremely uh
something that's done it's dumb I get
carried away into it it's all ego
there's injury
um I will never even do one rep max like
10 rpe nothing like that bro I think the
most I've done is like a two rep max at
like a five or six RP and the most I've
done in terms of uh that was well before
my Peak and then in my Peak I think I
was doing anywhere from 275
actually I'm not I don't even know 225
to 275 for sure for reps at least 10
reps so anywhere from 225 to 275 that's
what I remember
yeah now I don't even bench
yeah someone asked how is your thing
what a good question for you is like uh
no can you hear me yeah
yeah
yeah I was about to say I hope no one
thinks that we're trying to like one-up
the other because first Romney went and
I win and then fire went and it sounded
like we were all trying to well it's not
like I was trying to one-up Rami and if
I was trying one of me but um that's not
the case at all like if y'all were to
see Romney's chest compared to montess
you'd be like oh mashallah this man got
the genetics for it I love listen so it
don't even matter if I'm over here
benching more than him actually I
specifically went first because I knew
my bench is going to be a low so I set
it up in that way so no worries it's it
don't even matter bro at the end of the
day like numbers is numbers
bro
how was your day what a nice question
bro
um
we'll leave it at that bro I think this
was generally the best question to close
it up no hey they don't want anything
from us they just want to know how we
doing bro
I'm gonna do that you guys don't show us
love bro you only come with us for
Fourth of us no I'm just playing but
this guy generally asked us how was your
day alhamdulillah I agree as well with
onion Romy
um and with that being said Rami
you have recently launched this
important thing this purpose this
project and you have a goal with that do
you want to quickly mention that bro
before we wrap this up because I
generally think there's so much value in
this bro yes about a kalafi so first and
foremost
um I was at a point uh in 2000 2019.
where I just got out of a you know I
wanted to marry someone kind of state
and it broke me man because it didn't
work out was really harsh and I've told
a story before it literally broke me and
I've it was a really rough time for me
and I found that you know there are very
specific things that really blessed me
and what I think the biggest blessing
was was being around good people I had
good friends and I remember you know
even one of them specifically was
telling me you're gonna look back on
this one day and say I needed that and I
believed them but it was hard to really
accept that now I'm telling you I needed
that and I'm very grateful alhamdulillah
that I went through that and I couldn't
sleep by night I couldn't eat I'm happy
I went through that because it has
blessed me tremendously alhamdulillah
and Allah has replaced that with
something so much better alhamdulillah
but what I took away from it is the
value of community I took away the value
of having good you know Brothers if
you're a brother or good sisters if
you're a sister around you and if you
don't have that in the home if you don't
have that around you you have to utilize
what you can so first let me plug
something that is free
which is the I3 Institute
that is where I got my community from
that is where I got like my second home
and it has blessed me amazingly
I I started crying during one of the
classes and my teacher came out to
console he paused the whole class to
come out and console me that is true you
know love and care may Allah bless them
and have mercy on him and the students
but while I decided to start was a
Brother's group session with the sole
purpose of being good masculine men
focusing on our goals developing
ourselves as men as Muslims as
individuals in in terms of our
livelihood and that includes finances
that includes our character that
includes our mannerism that includes
most importantly our Islam our religion
that includes in our with our families
with our friends and to keep each other
motivated held accountable before we
take into account the front of Allah the
whole point is for growth and
development especially from an Islamic
perspective Four Brothers if you are
interested and want to join it thank you
so much
you can sign up there if you have any
questions or if you can't afford it but
still need advice like I mentioned
before please just DM me on Instagram or
the three Muslims we do try and get to
everybody uh to help out Insha'Allah
um two quick things not necessarily
questions but we should talk about them
at least put them up I mean right rami's
channel is underrated I have mean bro
[ __ ] and then the last thing very
beautiful reminder uh on her bro read it
all bro come on you got to read one of
them
guys be beautiful to your parents and be
patient on what befalls you
a low strengthen you and ease the way
for you I mean I mean
all right until Friday at 6 PM EST we'll
see you guys then and with that being
said